hi guys so I'm here in Pittsburgh for
stuff of us 2010 now Pittsburgh radio
station 96 one kiss FM every year has
this event where they have a bunch of
buses and people bring their toys to
stuff and fool the buses now all these
toys are going to donated for Toys for
Tots and Mattel was kind enough just let
me some toys to put the bus so let's all
right we're gonna take our toys and put
them on the bus are you ready I'm ready
I don't know you don't know it's in the
Bahamas there's a lot of toys in here
really aren't messing around ya know Hot
Wheels mattel isn't must know I wheels
yeah this is the Mattel box of love how
about slice Hot Wheels this is right
whoa we got what we got in here don't
see the backpack let me tell you anybody
make funny inferno are they just
respected you slept girl many buses you
guys sold so far this is boss 11 pretty
close to being full I mean we can stack
a few but plus 11 timing Mattel and you
pretty much just closed out plus 11 I'd
say so everyone's probably wondering
where these toys gals like Marines Toys
for Tots all kids in like western
Pennsylvania stuff like that so kids who
may not have a Christmas they wake up
and they go all right so we just put all
of our toys into the bus and this is the
trailer where they take all the toys
from the bus put them in the trailer and
then take them to donate
oh you came at the perfect time oh yeah
although like local monroeville like
fire departments get together they just
went to toys r us and spent 3 grand
now every fire truck is rolling up here
to deliver some toys
oh boy
everyone pretty much retired fighters
right now like a firebreak hot sauce run
and get my water
that said this year we're doing pretty
much the firefighters feel like I'm
playing call of duty except they're not
yeah it's closer
a fire truck
ok guys so that was a double bust 2010 I
hope you enjoyed the video and now I'm
going on what do you guys do to help out
during the holidays this is what my Tom
does and yeah I won't hear from you guys
don't leave me a comment below and happy
holidays oh yeah I do you like my hat my
hat yeah Bruce Lee pretty sweet
cool
Oh
you're so cute I can't even handle look
at your like waddling around oh ok angel